ça va donc de plus en plus vite en
allemagne de l'est ce matin le bureau
politique du parti communiste à
démissionner à la demande des gones
krenz qui hier limoger le gouvernement
mais il s'agit là de concessions
minimales pour une population qui
doutent de ses nouveaux dirigeants
pour preuve depuis hier 11 mille
nouveaux allemands de l'est se sont
réfugiés en rfa reportage de notre
envoyé spécial à berlin-est philippe
rochot la voix unique du socialisme
c'est sous cet emblème que le comité
central du parti communiste est-allemand
va faire peau neuve après les démissions
du bureau politique
avec un mot d'ordre le renouveau c'est
la seule chance pour le ssd de garder le
peu de confiance qui lui restent auprès
de la population qui ce matin
attendaient avec impatience l'ouverture
des kiosques
seule la vieille gare de paresse est
inquiète des démissions j'espère que le
comité central va trouver des solutions
dans tous les domaines et que nous
allons sortir de tout ça vous êtes du
parti je suis depuis 60 ans un camarade
membre du parti et que pensez vous de
ces manifestations
moi je dis que c'est la terreur des rues
malgré le grand chambardement le
renouveau a déjà commencé à la
télévision est-allemande par exemple où
l'on n'a pas hésité à montrer les
manifestations autour du siège du comité
central demandant des élections libres
après que tous les journalistes aient
fait leurs excuses au public pour
l'avoir trompée pendant 40 ans
c'est l'élément nouveau dans la vie du
pays ici encore le nouveau porte parole
du gouvernement appelle en direct les
citoyens à ne pas céder à la tentation
de l'exode vers l'allemagne fédérale et
à rester chez eux
nous avons besoin de vous dire dit il
nous avons besoin de vos forces
enfin il moment même où l'une des
figures de l'opposition barbell volaille
intervenait pour dire qu'elle était
sceptique sur l'avenir la télévision
annonce est immédiatement les démissions
du gouvernement et ce matin du bureau
politique du parti communiste
est-allemand
avec cette cascade de démissions au
moment où s'ouvre la réunion du comité
central du parti communiste c'est toute
la rue qui a l'impression d'avoir
remporté une victoire car c'est bien la
rue qui criait dans les rues de la fiche
et dans les rues de berlin est hier soir
dirigeants démission nous voulons des
hommes nouveaux